[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 7 avril j moins 3
avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle douze candidats sont en
lice pour le scrutin présentation dans
cette édition est alors que l'abstention
s'annonce records nous sommes allez vous
poser une question irez-vous voter
dimanche vos réponses à suivre l'hommage
à la mi journée de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines à
laurent bouvet le politologue
cofondateur du mouvement le printemps
républicain est décédé en décembre
dernier à l'âge de 53 ans il enseigne la
science politique depuis 2011 a lu vs
kull et puis suite et fin de notre
dossier de la rédaction cette semaine tv
60,18 mettait en lumière des
influenceurs yvelinois dernier numéro ce
soir consacrée à vinh sky le youtuber du
football 1,3 million d'abonnés à créer
son propre club dans le département
[Musique]
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle se déroule ce dimanche 10
avril 2022 et parmi les candidats on
retrouve emmanuel macron pour la
république en marche marine le pen pour
le rassemblement national jean luc
mélenchon pour la france insoumise
yannick jadot d'europe écologie les
verts anne hidalgo pour le parti
socialiste jean lassalle pour résistons
filet poutou pour le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste eric zemmour pour
reconquête valérie pécresse pour les
républicains nathalie arthaud avec la
lutte ouvrière
nicolas dupont aignan pour debout la
france et puis fabien roussel du parti
communiste français
pour rappel lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle en 2017 c'est emmanuel
macron qui est arrivé en tête dans les
yvelines avec 28 86 % des votes pour son
parti en marche suivie de près par le
party les républicains
représenter en 2017 par françois fillon
avec
27,25 % des suffrages
arrivait ensuite la france insoumise
avec 16 65% des voix représentées par
jean luc mélenchon et puis le front
national aujourd'hui rassemblement
national représenté par marine le pen
arrivait en quatrième position dans le
département avec kate 12 92 % des votes
du côté des électeurs et yvelinois en
2010 est le taux de votants dans le
département était de 90 12 34 % cette
année encore beaucoup divinement prévu
de se déplacer aux urnes ce dimanche
c'est important de voter pour donner
notre avis
si on va changer les choses et produit
le pays
c'est un protêt de s'exprimer en plus
d'être un droit c'est un devoir pour moi
surtout dans la situation actuelle je
pense que c'est important d'aller donner
sa voix et de se faire représenter au
niveau du territoire comme je ne sais
plus qui a dit eh bien si on s'occupe
pas de la politique c'est la politique
qui s'occupe de vous donc oui je vais
aller voter comme je vais toujours fait
depuis depuis que j'ai 18 ans un choix
déjà arrêté pour la plupart à trois
jours du premier tour pas je vais voter
parce que j'ai toujours voté et toujours
pour le même parti du côté macro et a
aucun problème
ça mais qu'ils avaient mené à yaoundé a
très bien et dépendant de coghead et
l'affectivité bon chose est bon il ya
des gens qui critiquent moi je le trouve
que c'est trop bien oui mon choix est
arrêté et bah j'ai fait tout simplement
en regardant les programmes les diverses
interviews oui je vais voter parce que
j'ai des convictions et je veux que
monsieur macron parts et j'ai des
convictions moi je vais aller voter pour
valérie pécresse ça est clairement c'est
un choix de voter blanc fait pour
exprimer mon vote ma tante en compte le
vote blanc automatiquement
on est toujours hésitant aller voter
mais on ira quand même ce qui mélange un
peu les parties et qu'on était à
regrouper les partis serait peut-être
intéressant de voter pour quelqu'un mais
du coup là y'a personne qui meurt qui me
parle ce dimanche les bureaux de vote
seront ouverts de 8 heures à 20 heures
[Musique]
bonjour je suis olivier de montlivault
le dirigeant fondateur de sos
accessoires nous sommes une pme d'une
soixantaine de personnes nous sommes le
leader en france de l'auto réparation et
de la vente de pièces détachées pour
réparer les appareils électroménagers
cette élection présidentielle se déroule
très clairement dans un contexte où les
sujets économiques et écologiques sont
majeurs on parle de évidemment de la
question du pouvoir d'achat on parle de
l'avenir de notre environnement de notre
de notre planète chez sos accessoires
c'est au coeur de notre de notre
activité est au coeur de nos
problématiques le fait de réparer
permettrait largement
d'économiser une partie de de vos
ressources de nous de nos salaires
ce que j'attends c'est que nos
gouvernants continuent à améliorer le
cadre
réglementaire 'l'indice de réparabilité
il faut l'étendre à beaucoup plus de
deux catégories il faut renforcer
c'est à ces critères il faut le pousser
jusqu'à un indice de durabilité c'est
par exemple peut-être de réfléchir à une
limite une diminution de la tva sur la
réparation ça va aussi dans le bon sens
pour l'autre balance commerciale parce
qu'il n'y a pas de mystère tous les
appareils que nous achetons à 99% ils
viennent de l'étranger donc ils ont une
sacrée empreinte carbone et ils viennent
sacrément déséquilibré notre notre
balance commerciale alors que de
d'allonger la durée de vie de ces as de
ces appareils en plus de faire faire des
économies et de préserver la planète va
permettre la au sida
de recréer des emplois et des emplois
non délocalisables
[Musique]
nous vous en parlions hier la famille de
samuel patty a porté plainte contre les
ministères de l'intérieur et de
l'éducation nationale pour non
empêchement de crime et non assistance à
personne en péril l'enseignant
d'histoire géographie avait été décapité
par un terroriste le 16 octobre 2020
près du collège du bois d'aulne de
conflans sainte honorine que pour avoir
montré des caricatures de mahomet ce
matin chez nos confrères de rmc
l'avocate de la famille a précisé les
raisons de cette action en justice
contre le gouvernement et les proches du
professeur dénonce une série de
dysfonctionnements et négligence une
rupture d'anonymat de samuel patick n'a
pas été mis sous protection des
mécanismes sécuritaires non activé une
grave erreur d' analyse de la part des
services de renseignement à l'auteur
david di nota revient justement sur cet
engrenage fatal dans son livre j'ai
exécuté un chien de l'enfer une contre
enquête sur l'assassinât de samuel pâtit
ce qui est très frappant c'est ce que
vous dites au four de deux états
d'esprit qu'on pourrait appeler la
machine de l'éducation nationale il faut
il ya un renversement des valeurs qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui bah c'est plus quand
il ya un conflit c'est plus l'élève qui
ont dit bah tiens toi bien en gros c'est
au professeur cocon convard projet faire
des reproches c'est absolument juste je
dirais que la contradiction qui est au
coeur de mon livre c'est le fait que
cette on a demandé à samuel pâti de
s'excuser pour une rumeur créé par une
élève qui n'était pas dans la classe
comme si c'était lui qui est comme si
c'était la victime de la rumeur qui
devait alors en quelque sorte s'excuser
de la rumeur qui le calomnier je
rappelle simplement pour la clarté le
contenu de cette rumeur qui est
extrêmement grave qui consistait à dire
que sa mère pattie avait exclu les
musulmans les élèves musulmans de sa
classe parce que musulman donc cette
rumeur qui faisait de sa mère pattie un
islamophobe va évidemment créer une
dynamique infernale et mon livre
consiste à décrire décrypter décortiqué
l'attitude de l'éducation nationale face
à ce que les anglais appellent un
testing c'est à dire une façon que les
islamistes de tester vraiment une
structure pour voir si elle traque et
comment elle peut craquer
[Musique]
le redoux était un professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin il est un grand
défenseur un grand combattant de la
laïcité il est décédé au mois de
décembre dernier très jeune à 53 ans des
suites d'une longue maladie et un
hommage lui était rendu à l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin hommage qui
est résumé dans ce livre laurent bouvet
portrait d'un intellectuel engagé
[Musique]
où il a été beaucoup attaqué par la
gauche par sa formation politique celle
dont il est originaire et ça c'est bien
dommage parce que laurent bouvet a
défendu au fond de gauche qui une gauche
anti totalitaire et l'autre partie de la
gauche à la gauche qu'on va dire
peut-être plus pluraliste a sans doute
voulu par peut-être volonté de
récupération politique d'un certain
nombre de voix est bien tendre vers un
modèle a plutôt à l'américaine qui
correspond pas du tout à notre histoire
en réalité notre histoire notre laïcité
c'est la séparation du politique et du
religieux mais dans le respect de la
liberté religieuse et afin de permettre
à toutes les religions et bien d'être
protégé et c'est là que le clivage va se
faire entre une partie de la gauche qui
se tournent vers ce modèle américain et
puis et puis la gauche classique celle
de nos pères de l'arrêt de la troisième
république qui fait de ce principe de
laïcité est bien un socle un socle pour
le vivre ensemble
[Musique]
dans les pas de laurent bouvet en effet
ce serait celle du courage ne pas avoir
peur de défendre ses valeurs
républicaines
y compris quand on est fragilisé y
compris quand on est fatigué compris
quand il ya des accords et des
désaccords toi que c'est vraiment
important surtout dans nos universités
de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
continuer de débattre d'être en accord
ou en désaccord mais au moins d'avoir ce
ce débat d'idées la question du courage
oui elle nous interroge beaucoup
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans des temps
incertains je crois que nous devons
c'est une mission que nous avons nous
les nous les enseignants chercheurs
porter l'esprit des lumières comme une
boussole et cela dans les pas de
rambouillet
[Musique]
la disparition de philippe brunel le
maire adjoint en charge de l'urbanisme à
montigny le bretonneux est décédé ce
mardi 5 avril à l'âge de 61 ans membre
de l'équipe municipale depuis 2008 il a
notamment présidé le conseil de quartier
du village à partir de 2014 l'élu a
accompagné également de grands projets
pour la commune tout récemment le forum
des arts charles aznavour la ville par
la voix de son maire laurin merker se
souvient d'un homme gentil soucieux des
autres et très investi tv 78 adresse ses
condoléances à la famille et aux proches
du défunt du matériel médical en
partance pour l'ukraine il a été réunie
hier mercredi en mairie de montigny le
bretonneux une collecte spécifique opéré
par l'association des médecins des trois
villages à l'initiative d'alain giniès
maire adjoint de la commune du matériel
d'intervention avec notamment des kits
hémorragie pour les sauveteurs ils ont
pu être achetés grâce à la générosité
des médecins 3500 euros ont pu être
récoltés un transporteur de 40 tonnes
doit partir dans les prochaines heures
chargées de l'ensemble des dons dans la
région
[Musique]
il il a côtoyé les plus grands et ses
vidéos font le tour du monde depuis 2012
vince qui est aujourd'hui l'inde et
influençant les plus connus de france
avec plus d'un million d'abonnés depuis
2010 est le youtuber a décidé de lancer
un nouveau projet dans les yvelines en
créant sa propre équipe de football dans
la région mantaise levine sky fc
l'objectif selon lui c'est sûr raconté
des histoires sordides etc et bah a créé
un club de foot c'est un petit peu la
suite logique pour quelqu'un qui aime
bien le foot c'est à dire si on pouvait
pas créer un concept un collectif avec
des amis etc donc j'ai proposé un peu
des amis d'enfance des gens je
connaissais même désabonner aussi j'ai
recruté si c'était chaud pour le projet
et c'est vous accédez en fait c'est pour
continuer toujours à raconter une
histoire sur youtube depuis 2019 le club
est affilié à la fédération française de
football la structure a commencé en 6e
division de district évolue désormais en
cinquième division chaque rencontre est
enregistré et diffusé sur internet des
milliers de personnes suivent les
aventures du club une source de
motivation pour les joueurs mais
également les adversaires on nous attend
beaucoup au tournant tous les week-ends
on nous croit privilégiée mais pour nous
on fait abstraction de ça et est
vraiment je vous fous pour le plaisir
c'est pas du tout la même échelle on a
un peu comme paris où tout le monde veut
nous battre quand elvis kfc forcément
tout le monde veut nous battre donc on
n'est pas pareil hein je précise mais
voilà c'était dans l'image aujourd'hui
l'équipe senior est à la troisième place
du classement et vise la montée en fin
de saison une aventure sportive que
vince cas issus principalement sur le
bord du terrain regardant ses joueurs
que youtuber président n'a joué que 45
minutes depuis le début de la saison
c'était compliqué alors plusieurs
casquettes d'être président d'être de
gérer la communication de manager du
club est d'être joueur aussi en plus
leur côté des jours très bon à mon poste
qui sont même plus fort que moi dans
voiture même pas de même pas de débat là
dessus donc ça va a prévu sur ma licence
de joueur l'idée c'est que je sois plus
dans les plans on va dire du coach
bon la saison après le tour là au cas où
si un produit vince cas espère encore
faire grandir ce club l'influent sort a
créé une académie qui a pour objectif
d'encadrer des jeunes footballeurs sur
le plan sportif scolaire et culturel
pour les seniors vinh sky rêve de les
emmener un jour en ligue 1
[Musique]
comme tous les jours ou presque julie
revient s'entraîner dans sa salle de
sport située à guyancourt pendant une à
deux heures ce sportif de 26 ans
transpirent pour sculpter son corps son
objectif être performant dans le
culturisme au bodybuilding anglais un
sport qu'il a débuté à l'âge de 16 ans
alors qu'il faisait 60 kg en fait était
à la base un sport que je faisais
vraiment injuste pour les sculpter un
corps me sentir bien dans ma peau et
avec le temps en fait quand tu commences
à prendre un petit peu les habitudes
quand tu commences à y aller à des
heures régulières tu rencontres des gens
les mêmes gens régulièrement et de ce
fait en fait ça devient vraiment un
endroit un petit cocon où tu passes une
heure deux heures par jour et au final
en fait avec le temps tu continues à te
documenter à découvrir un petit peu ce
domaine là après dix ans de pratique
julien n'est plus au stade de
l'observation mais de la compétition
libinois participe à des concours
abatteurs espère un jour obtenir sa
carte professionnelle
pour atteindre cet objectif l'athlète
d'un mètre 77 pour cent kilos doit
convaincre sur scène un jury lors de ces
rendez vous ici dans sa catégorie les
observateurs évaluent le buste des
participants selon plusieurs critères
nous on est plus en fait homme de plage
donc c'était là on va avoir des
positions dites naturelles donc les
fidjiens ya quand même un travail
spécifique de la contraction on essaie
d'être le plus relâchée possible et
effectivement d'avoir une prestance
d'une aisance sur scène ce qui est plus
important d'avoir ce qu'on appelle le
posing et en fait on est jugé sur sa sur
la comme j'ai dit sur la symétrie sur la
masse musculaire mais également sur ce
qu'on va dégager sur scène c'est un peu
comme un ange en vigueur un concours de
miss france mais pour des mecs musclés
pour faire découvrir sa passion au plus
grand nombre julien sortir un film sur
son parcours dans le milieu du
bodybuilding un documentaire de 25
minutes projeté pour la première fois à
paris au mois de mars son objectif
combattre les clichés sur ces
disciplines moi aujourd'hui à mon petit
niveau à ma petite échelle j'essaye de
combat'' ajustements faire comprendre
qu'on n'est pas tous ceux des
tout dans le dans les bras dans le
cerveau le but c'est vraiment de faire
comprendre que voilà on peut faire cette
discipline
mais quelqu'un de normal aussi d'avoir
un business à côté de faire sa vie et
d'être quelqu'un d'intelligent parce que
voilà il faut savoir que malgré tout
faut quand même être cadré et
intelligent pour faire ce sport là
julien va maintenant continuer à
sculpter son corps sur cette année 2022
avant de reprendre la compétition au
premier semestre 2023 avec toujours cet
objectif en tête passer professionnel
[Musique]